I see you sell LMNT in the cutters clinic store. Do you evaluate other sugar-free electrolytes
and decide that one was best? Well, to be honest with you, there's some things that are in our
store that I would recommend to patients. So just be an honest. So we don't, you know, we try our
best to pull things out of our store that I don't, you know, because, okay, so let's say we carry
designs for health products. So, carrying designs for health products is great. So, you know,
me or a staff person would go through and put in all the designs for health products
into our store, you know, but the pricing on there do all of this. It's a lot of work and I
usually need some support in help in putting these things in. Now, when I have time, I can go
through it and like, I don't want to sell that. I don't agree with all every designs for health
product. That's why we don't have all of designs for health product in there. So it's the same thing
with any of the other products that we have in there. Now, I won't put in there typically a line
some moments that I don't like and I don't support because I don't trust, you know, their practices
and I don't trust, you know, the company itself. So there's some companies that people ask for and
we don't carry those. I think there's a lot of good nutritional companies out there now compared to
just a few years ago where there was a lot fewer good nutritional companies. But that would be
that I would vouch for every product that we have on the store. So that's not how I want you members
shopping anyhow. I don't want you to go, I'm going to look for this and I'm going to go buy this.
And we get that often and sometimes I have to ask Megan to call you and say, Hey, you know, Dr.
Hunter would recommend this, not this. Why, you know, sometimes people just search, I get it,
they're just searching for a vitamin B12 and they can't remember the last one they had or something
or they are told that they need one and then they pick one that I wouldn't recommend for that.
Okay, let's use methyl products for an example. We have a lot of supplements that are methyl based
because we have a lot of patients that aren't cancer patients, but often we will get one of our
cancer patients typically at somebody that isn't done the Zoom calls very often and typically at somebody
that we haven't talked to for several years and they'll order a product and I might have,
if I catch it, I say, they say to Megan, can you call XYZ and tell them that I would never recommend
that for them? And sometimes they're ordering it for somebody else in their family. I get that,
but I certainly, you know, even though I might have talked to that person for a couple of years,
I don't want them to take heed something that I would never tell them to take.
But I don't always catch that and Megan doesn't catch those things, she's filling the orders. So
if you as a patient that stayed in touch with me and tried to follow what we're recommending,
want something else, maybe for somebody else or a family member, still it's a good thing to talk to me.
And you can ask the question on the Zoom call, like whoever asked the question about
their husband has elevated CRP, you know, you can ask that question if we don't get too many
family member questions on the Zoom calls. But for the most part, I try to evaluate the majority
of our supplements. We have, I don't know, 5,000 skews on our store. So I don't evaluate everything
and these companies are changing things all the time. It's very hard. So as far as LMNT recharge,
I think that's a okay product. I don't see that as a bad product. I think it's a good product.
I don't typically recommend that because I don't not typically recommend it a lot of electrolytes
for people, but that product, I think it's a fine product, designs for health as an electrolyte product
as well. And I think it's literally the same. So because an electrolyte product's typically
just going to be sodium and potassium and magnesium. It's just going to be a mineral product.
And you just don't want a poorly bowed mineral and either one of those electrolyte products are
just fine. So when a person's thinking they have to take electrolytes, they often think that they
have to take a product that's labeled as an electrolyte product. So electrolytes are going
to be minerals. So taking a good mineral is going to give you that electrolyte balance. Unless
your sodium's way off and you need to be taking sodium, electrolyte products by themselves are
typically created for the market of the athletic market. So some athletes that's working out
three hours a day that's what I like to pay three hours a day has a lead body mass of zero. And
they need to keep their electrolytes up for their heart. That's typically going to be the electrolyte
market. Most other people, when they talk about wanting to keep up their electrolytes, they're just
going to take a good mineral product. And that's what I would typically recommend the reacted
multiband or the our clear multiband product.